[Music]
rush limbaugh passed away
in february after 30 years of completely
dominating talk radio of course and
since then
some have wondered who will be replacing
him well today we learned the answer
premier networks announced that clay
travis the founder
of outkick and buck sexton who often
appears in the show
will take over the three-hour time slot
the program which is set to begin
on june 21st will be called the clay
travis and
buck sexton show it's expected to air
all over the country from noon to 3 p.m
eastern
and we will be listening in the meantime
clay travis joins us
and we're happy to have him
congratulations clay that's amazing news
are you nervous uh i'm not
nervous tucker first of all thanks for
having me you do incredible work
and uh i i don't think you could be
nervous about stepping in
that i'm not a replacement buck and i
are not replacements for
rush limbaugh because no one replaces a
legend
but what you can do is continue the
fight and you know this because you do
it every night
there is so much insanity going on in
this country right now
and i've done sports for the last six
years uh tucker and it's slowly on daily
sports radio
slowly just spiraled more and more into
the
cataclysmically ridiculous and so i'm
excited finally to just be picking up a
sword and be able to swing back
every single day at all the ign
ignoramuses out there in the idiots and
then income poops
and actually be able to stand up for i
think a
huge number of people out there who
worry every time they get on twitter or
facebook or instagram
and want to share their opinion and then
think is it worth it
am i going to end up losing my job over
this
i think you do and i think certainly we
will speak for a lot of people who don't
feel like they can speak
amen i envy you having three hours
you'll get to about three percent of the
insanity we get to about one percent
um it's just too much but i want to
throw i just want to throw a story
right up into your grill and see how you
respond get your thoughts on this
advice that we read in slate.com
the dear prudence comment begins this
way this is the advice column
my husband won't take off his mask even
for sex
we're both vaccinated now when will this
stop the author adds that her husband
quote
does not change his mask very often and
it's
smelly and soiled so
how many first of all you imagine can
relate
uh probably far too many tucker not a
lot of fox news viewers i wouldn't
imagine
i would say this first of all if the
woman had any sense at all she would
leave her husband because
if you're masking up at this point like
why do you want to be with such an
emasculated loser and be betrothed to
him for the rest of your life i would
lose my mind if i were this woman
uh having said that you know i'm about
to go out to dinner with my own wife
tucker uh maybe i should put on
four masks just to be safe you know so
that i don't in any way
uh manage to impinge on anyone i mean
this this is just
it has moved beyond uh the the theater
of the
absurd to just a level of mindlessness
that the party of science
is now embracing fundamentally
anti-science
beliefs with no no no
legitimate basis in reality tucker it's
just it's mindless
banal insanity i wonder though i mean
once you've admitted that you wear a
mask a surgical mask
a soiled surgical mask in the intimate
moments with your wife like there's no
going back from that you've basically
just told the world like i'm i'm crazy
but you don't even realize you're crazy
i mean
can people like that recover no
i don't think people can't can recover
and that's the thing i mean
you've seen people as all the mask
mandates have thankfully finally come
falling down you thought there would be
a great
mass of people running out into the
streets to have a great deal of fun and
i think what you're seeing is
this has become the security blanket of
many left wingers they need to have the
mask on
because it gives them an identity it is
a security blanket for their life
and it's absolutely ridiculous and
absurd obedient little drones there
clay congratulations to you and buck and
we will be listing
what what a cool opportunity i know
you're going to kill it thank you for
coming thanks by the way
to ed hartman and also to julie talbot
who made this happen phenomenal people
i can't wait to do them justice on the
show amen
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else